hanté pour commencer cette émission nous
sommes avec deux sénateurs céline boulay
speroni bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes la vice présidente
du groupe d'amitié france royaume-uni 6
au sénat vous connaissez bien sûr très
bien le royaume uni on va en parler avec
vous et puis olivier cadic vous êtes
avec nous en duplex merci également
d'être avec nos sénateurs de les
français de l'étranger vous vivez à
londres vous nous direz ce que la reine
représenter pour l'angleterre et pour
les anglais et l'angleterre qui est
évidemment plongé dans la tristesse ce
matin avant de vous entendre on va
regarder ce portrait de la reine
elizabeth ii et les signaux de radio tu
as et gaspard flammes il est 19 heures
40 en france quand de l'autre côté de la
manche la bbc interrompt ses programmes
le présentateur vêtus de noir prononce
les mots que tous les britanniques
redoute parking on travaille le palais
de buckingham vient d'annoncer la mort
de sa majesté la reine elizabeth 2 la
reine s'est éteinte dans l'après midi à
l'âge de 96 ans dans son château privé
de balmoral en écosse entourée de sa
famille proches dont ses quatre enfants
celui qui est encore à ce moment là le
prince charles la princesse anne et les
princes andrew et edward les médecins de
la reine avait alerté sur son état de
santé préoccupant c'est par un tweet que
la famille royale annonce officiellement
son décès la reine est mort paisiblement
à balmoral cet après midi elle aura
régné un peu plus de soixante dix ans
sur le royaume uni un record de
longévité pour un monarque britannique
en juin dernier elle célébrait
d'ailleurs son jubilé de platine l'une
des dernières apparitions publiques
entouré de la famille royale et de tous
ces sujets une vie au service de la
monarchie en 1952 à la suite du décès de
son père le roi george 6 la princesse
elisabeth devient la reine elizabeth 2
sous les yeux des caméras à tout juste
25 ans elle aura vu défiler pas moins de
quinze premiers ministres de winston
churchill au milieu du xxème siècle ali
strauss qu'elle a rencontré mardi
dernier elisabeth deux incarner pour
beaucoup la stabilité inébranlable
malgré les crises 8 britannique sur dix
disait apprécier son action et ce malgré
des périodes plus sombres après la mort
de la princesse diana en 1997
la reine a attendu cinq jours pour
s'exprimer publiquement expliquant avoir
voulu protéger ses petits enfants une
ati thud que la population lui a alors
reproché l'histoire de la reine
d'angleterre est aussi intimement liée à
celle de son mari le prince philip celui
qu'elle considérait comme son rauque et
son soutien elle a accompagné et
conseillé tout au long de leurs 70 ans
de vie commune la reine lui avait fait
ses adieux en avril 2021 après le décès
de sa mère le prince charles a décrit un
moment de grande tristesse il devient
désormais le roi charles iii chargé de
régner sur le royaume uni et le
commonwealth
c'est les mollets de cette ville de
rennes quel a été votre réaction hier en
apprenant son décès j'ai été triste j'ai
été triste d'abord ge des grands amis
dans le peuple anglais j'ai été en
empathie avec eux je sais à quel point
ils étaient attachés à leur reine
c'était le ciment du peuple britannique
elle incarnait vraiment le britannique
c'était la grande bretagne
et c'était ce symbole d'unité qui a
traversé les époques avec cette
longévité extraordinaire qui est presque
anachronique aujourd'hui où le monde est
en proie à des divisions
à des stratégies de communication à des
changements elle elle incarnait cette
stabilité
avec toujours ce sérieux
[Musique]
cette humilité surtout cette stabilité
et ce sens du devoir qui dépasse les
stratégies de communication et qui
d'ailleurs touche toute la famille
royale très souvent on a parlé du fait
qu'elle aurait pu se destituer au profit
de charles qui attendaient depuis des
années de régner et bien non elle a
assumé jusqu'au dernier moment son rôle
de reine rappelez vous son discours
d'intronisation lorsqu à 25 ans elle
devient jaune règne et qu'elle explique
que que sa vie soit lent qu'elles soient
courtes jusqu'à son dernier souffle elle
sera le monarque britannique qu'elle a
été elle a tenu parole jusqu'au dernier
moment c'est en tout point admirable
ouais on va revenir évidemment sur sa
vie olivier cadic vous quel a été votre
réaction rappelle que vous viviez au
royaume uni le kent on imagine que ça a
été une émotion particulière pour vous
évidemment je suis juillet au royaume
uni depuis 25 ans maintenant et que
comme tout le monde j'ai été très
attristé par cette nouvelle la
disparition de la reine elizabeth ii
laisse personne indifférent bien sûr on
savait qu'elle était très diminué il ya
trois jours à peine elle recevait la
nouvelle première ministre li strauss à
balmoral il lui était impossible de
revenir au palais de buckingham donc
c'était quand même un signe important
l'annoncé de son décès hier a malgré
tout été une surprise à un vrai choc
pour tout le monde le royaume uni leur
ca rennes
calait c'est aussi
parce qu'est ce qu'elle représentait les
abeilles 2 pour le peuple britannique
s'est
elle incarne la résilience des
britanniques face à l'adversité
c'était la dignité en toutes
circonstances
et je crois qu'elle conservera à jamais
une place dans l'imaginaire collectif
britannique ils ont une profonde
affection pour leur souveraine et
certains vivent ce départ comme un
traumatisme
un deuil familial en ressent avec les
les échanges qu'on peut avoir avec
certains aient vraiment jeu profitait de
l'occasion pour adresser toute ma
sympathie toute ma solidarité au peuple
britannique car ils vivent même si
c'était attendu ils vivent une vraie
épreuve avec ce départ de une personne
qui va rester comme il l'est jean pascal
et les britanniques quand vous
connaissez bien au delà d'avoir perdu
leur souveraine ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir perdu une mère une grand mère
c'est ça c'est hydro vous savez tous un
rapport avec avec la reine c'est un
règne qui a duré 70 ans donc vous
imaginez est là elle s'en va à l'âge de
96 ans donc pratiquement tous les
britanniques sont nés en connaissant
la reine elizabeth ii joie qui a donc
dans le coeur de chaque britannique la
reine c'est un rapport à la tradition
la couronne c'est le signe de la
continuité nationale mais elle a aussi
accompagner le changement la modernité
est un d'ailleurs la première ministre
hier soir lice trust a rappelé dans son
allocution que la reine était un roc sur
lequel la grande bretagne moderne a été
fondé puis je pense aussi aux propos du
président de la république qui a rendu
hommage à une reine de coeur qui a
marqué à jamais son pays son siècle il a
tout à fait raison
mais aussi que la reine était également
une amie de la france et ça c'est
peut-être un message qui devrait
inspirer la nouvelle première ministre
hier va revenir évidemment sur sur cette
déclaration des manuels mâcon mais sur
elizabeth 2 c'était un lien évidemment
affectif entre elles et les britanniques
olivier cadic disaient les et bêtes 2
c'est aussi le royaume uni moderne
est-ce que c'est aussi la place du
royaume uni dont le monde et les abbés
de ski si le royaume uni on est là dans
monte c'est grâce à elle elle est l'une
des personnalités les plus connues mais
de toute évidence il ya une spécificité
britannique il suffisait de voir moi
j'ai été très touché par l'aspect et
l'annoncent du journaliste de la bbc
hier qui incarnait vraiment ce deuil et
on sentait tout le deuil du peuple
britannique
à travers ce journaliste de la bbc la
bbc vous savez qu'elle a été
omniprésente lors de son son
couronnement et elle faisait rentrer
d'une certaine manière avec son
couronnement cette jeune femme la grande
bretagne dans la modernité déjà rappelez
vous qu elle s'est imposée dans un monde
d'hommes qu'elle a vécu la première
guerre mondiale qu'elle conduisait des
camions parce qu'elle était sur le sous
lieutenant dans l'armée terrestre et
qu'elle a voulu avec son mari que son
commandement soit télévisé soit télévisé
des allées voit une forme de modernité à
faire entrer sans couronnement dans les
foyers des britanniques donc non
seulement elle incarne le peuple
britannique mais il ya ce lien fusionnel
entre le peuple britannique et la reine
est bien évidemment ce rayonnement dans
le monde et d'ailleurs l'émotion
aujourd'hui elle est mondiale et tous
les chefs d'état c'était un chef d'état
lui rendent hommage et on sent cette
émotion palpable qui n'a rien du tout
d'anecdotique ou 2 du ressort de la
midinette rit bien au contraire elle est
vraiment très très sérieuse très
ressenti cette émotion c'est elle qui a
donné olivier cadic sa place
particulière au royaume uni dans le
monde de par sa personnalité
face au destin elle a toujours été
exemplaire elle a incarné les valeurs
morales la résilience de tout un peuple
est très jeune ma collègue céline l'a
appelée et elle a une conscience aiguë
son rôle d'aider son premier discours et
en 1940 elle avait 14 ans seulement elle
a prononcé un discours à la bbc c'était
pour donner courage aux enfants devenus
orphelins ou qui devaient être évacuées
pour fuir les bombardements à londres et
déjà elle était parfaite sincère et elle
le disait je suis avec vous alors on
parle de modernité par effectivement le
fait que son mariage avaient été
télévisées mais c'est juste que dans la
manière d'annoncer son départ par un
tweet c'est ça montre qu'elle a été elle
a tout le suivi toute cette évolution
elle et elle incarne quelque chose de
très profond
elle incarne aussi on disait on va en
parler l'unité l'unité du royaume uni la
reine d'angleterre est décédé dans son
château de balmoral en écosse au moment
où les causses connaît les velléités
d'indépendance est ce qu'on peut voir
une signification à ce décès en terre
écossaise
je crois que je crois que non c'est ça
pas de rapports lâche moi que je crois
que la reine a quand même toujours
incarné justement cette unité du royaume
c'est
maintenant la grande bretagne l'école
fait partie de la grande bretagne le
royaume uni c'est le royaume uni de
grande bretagne et d'irlande du nord
elle incarne cette unité maintenant elle
a vécu aussi ce démembrement quand on
voit ce que représentait le royaume uni
quand elle est devenue reine est ce que
c'est aujourd'hui effectivement avec ses
menace d'implosion dans la dans le
prolongement du bric site effectivement
elle mais elle a toujours su incarner
quand même 7 cette union donc là
aujourd'hui je pense que la
problématique est différente c'est
rendre hommage tout le monde est dans
l'émotion rendre hommage à cette
personnalité exceptionnelle qui nous
aura tous marqués et aujourd'hui je
crois que tout le monde est concentré là
dessus il faut pas y voir un signal
politique modeste et enterrée par mois
je pense sincèrement qu'on y voit le
signal qu'on a envie d'y voir et je
pense que c'est très symptomatique comme
moment même de sa mort on se pose cette
question là il faut rappeler que
l'angleterre traverse une triple crise
assez exceptionnel l'angleterre et
rentrer en récession il ya une crise
économique il ya une crise politique et
de fait une crise sociale et c'est
symbole d'unité incarné par la reine va
peut-être aller au delà de son décès
c'est en tout cas ce qui est en train de
se passer et on peut y voir le symbole
qu'on souhaite et je trouve ça
symptomatique intéressante est
personnellement
au royaume-uni peut-être atténuer ses
velléités d'indépendance sur certains à
côté en tout cas par exemple sur la
famille royale on voit qu'elle l'a réuni
temporairement autour d'elle on espère
que ça va durer on a quelques craintes
là dessus mais le symbole de la famille
royale étant le symbole de toute la
nation on peut espérer que en tout cas
cela jouera sur la crise avec écosse
effectivement cette famille royale elle
finit son reine elizabeth ii avec une
extraordinaire popularité pourtant elle
a connu évidemment 70 ans de rennes des
hauts des bas aussi bien sur le plan
politique sur le plan personnel avec
peut-être un simple un symptôme en 1997
au moment de la mort de lady di ou là la
monarchie a quelque peu vaciller la
monarchie a pu montrer à un moment
qu'elle avait pris des distances
peut-être bien involontaire avec le
peuple lady diana était la princesse du
peuple on a vu toutes les réactions je
pense que peut-être que la reine à ce
moment là n'avait pas mesuré mais ça a
duré de trois jours elle s'est rattrapé
ensuite en faisant un discours
d'ailleurs assez émouvant et je me
rappelle des commentaires à l'époque il
disait qu'elle était dans son rôle et
qu'elle était jamais vraiment sorti de
sa réserve et cinq jours après elle
avait montré en descendant dans la rue
d'ailleurs il ya des images très fortes
où elle avait été à la rencontre du
peuple ce qui montrait qu'elle savait
évoluer aussi évoluer rapidement et
quant à cinq jours après à la fesse
discours finalement les britanniques lui
ont pardonné donc c'était en 70 ans de
règne il y a eu un ou deux événements ou
les britanniques on peut lui en vouloir
mais ça a duré quelques jours voilà en
70 ans de règne alors que vous avez des
hommes politiques aujourd'hui qui
traverse crise sur crise et c'est ça qui
est assez intéressant olivier cadic en
70 ans de règne il n'y a jamais eu une
rupture finalement très les abeilles de
et son peuple
quand une fois ce qu'est ce qu'elle
représente
est tellement profond donc c'est li na
rézon quelques une réaction
incomprise au moment de lui décès
accidentel de lady di a été très vite
surmontées moi ce qui m'a vraiment le
plus marqué ça aura été l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques à londres il ya tout
juste dix ans et quand on parle de
modernité qui pouvait imaginer de voir
la reine partir avec james bond monter
dans un hélicoptère
et puis arrivée dans le stade pour
lancer des jeux olympiques c'est c'était
toujours un clin d'oeil
fantastique elle savait se mettre
vraiment tout le temps en proximité avec
les britanniques c'est c'est ce lien
personnel il faut imaginer quand un
britannique allait à une garden party à
buckingham moi j'en ai connu
quelques-uns qui qui allait c'était
l'événement il avait ne serait-ce que un
instant croiser le regard de la reine eu
un échange je dirais de quelques
secondes il revenait de ça comme s'il
avait vécu le grand moment de leur
existence c'était sait il faut vraiment
la rencontre et les britanniques et
partager ces moments là sentir leurs
émotions pour comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui aucune profond de leur être
ces nouveaux l'espagne elle a su évoluer
avec son temps évolué avec son peuple
évolue aussi avec les nouveaux outils on
se souvient de cette vidéo assez drôle
avec son petit-fils le prince harry
juste au moment où elle sortait un petit
peu de sa réserve et c'était une reine
qu'on ne voyait pas jusque là c'est
aussi ça la force d'elizabeth ii d'avoir
su évoluer avec son peuple oui monsieur
évoluerez son peuple faire ce genre on
se souvient de la vidéo avec paddington
au moment du du jubilé avec tout ce
monde mais justement ces petits
événements qui ont pu avoir lieu parce
qu'elle incarne et cette stabilité ce
sérieux et par conséquence et ses petits
événements ont au contraire montré
qu'elle pouvait être une reine moderne
sans toutefois écorné son image et c'est
ça qui a été intéressant et quand je
disais que c'était la tradition
perpétuelle au détriment des stratégies
de communication de l'instant elle
savait quand même un style et ses
petites radios de communication pour
montrer qu'elle était bien incarné dans
un bien bien installé dans son siècle
avec le peuple britannique et c'est ça
qui a été et qui a montré une grande
intelligence chez elle d'évolution
d'ailleurs on disait que c'était une une
très grande travailleuse beaucoup de
cultures très intelligente j'entendais
ce matin que les services de
renseignement britanniques l'ont rendue
au match qu'il ne faut en général jamais
il disait que tous les jours elle lisait
leur rapport elle s'informait vraiment
constamment ce sont des choses que
peut-être on ignore puisque la
constitution fait qu'elle ne parlait
jamais mais elle avait
une réelle influence sur ce qui se
passait en grande bretagne elle avait eu
rose bien plus politique que ce que la
constitution lui donne politique qu'est
ce que la constitution lui donner et
chefs d'état chef du gouvernement je
crois même mais c'est ça qui est
intéressant à voir à décrypter je pense
qu'il y aura beaucoup de littérature à
partir d'aujourd'hui on pourra analyser
tout ça et on vraiment on n'a pas fini
de le faire ouais elizabeth ii elle
entretenait une relation particulière
avec notre pays avec la france les
français étaient d'ailleurs attaché à la
reine ce matin elle est en une de tous
nos quotidiens régionaux on va faire le
tour des rédactions locales justement
dans cette édition spéciale on commence
en allant à rennes on retrouve ce mari
rob un bon jour ils marient merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journaliste à
ouest-france ouest-france qui bien
évidemment fait sa une sur l'a1
angleterre elizabeth 2 elle était the
queen oui effectivement très très
proches géographiquement de la grande
bretagne ouest devait être
dans cette édition spéciale de quatre
pages dans lesquelles nous pourrons
admirer d'ailleurs toutes les couleurs
portées par les sous le règne du maire
en une du bleu et du rouge en pages
intérieures et en dernière page nous
racontons évidemment les dernières
heures d'elizabeth ii et l'ambiance site
spécial régnant à londres en lien avec
notre correspondante sur place vous
dresse aussi un long portrait de la
souveraine en dernière page et puis et
puis nous parlons de charles iii 73 ans
le futur roi pour lequel le plus dur
commence à la tête d'une des royaumes en
perte de vitesse à l'international comme
au royaume uni il avait deux a joué un
rôle de ciment fondamental pour la
couronne l'icône quittant la scène ce
ciment tiendra-t-il s'interroge notre
éditorialiste laurent marchand ces défis
qui attend son successeur une épreuve de
vérité pour le kent pour l'unité du
royaume fragile et par le brr excite et
la légitimité même de pouvoir de
l'institution monarchique depuis hier
soir vous l'avez dit les hommages
d'internet une hausse pleuvent sur
londres en présence notamment en
provenance notamment de france dans
cette édition spéciale nous racontons
également comment il avait 2 a su
entretenir des relations d'amitié
privilégiés avec l'hexagone
et même vincent auriol et rené coty la
reine et la france qui le lui rendaient
bien elle est souvent venu à paris mais
aussi entouré voir les châteaux de la
loire qu'elle aime bien mais temps et
puis évidemment en normandie sur les
plages du débarquement
nous consacrons d'ailleurs un éclairage
particulier à ces séjours noir mans n y
étais chez zen françois mitterrand était
son chouchou - valéry giscard d'estaing
qu'elle juge être aux normes pour
emmanuel macron le souffle la souveraine
était le fil d'or voilier à la france et
l'angleterre la preuve de l'amitié
indéfectible entre les deux nations le
pilote s'est toujours duquel six à
charles iii maintenant de leur est ici
pourrait effectivement être ça c'est à
lire dans ouest france ce matin quatre
pages spéciales consacrées à la reine
d'angleterre évidemment votre une convoi
elizabeth ii elle était the queen c'est
à la une de ouest france merci beaucoup
et le mari robin d'un jour n'était avec
nos oliviers qui a dit qu'elle était la
relation entre la reine et la france
je crois que
l'histoire moi j'étais pas nés mais
l'histoire nous apprend que son premier
voyage à l'étranger était pour la france
elle parlait français c'était la seule
langue étrangère qu'elle parlait si je
ne me trompe pas
c'est que beaucoup ont témoigné du fait
que l parler remarquablement français
elle est aussi celle qui aura inauguré
le tunnel sous la manche puisque moi je
vais déficit sans le tunnel je pourrais
pas vivre de cette façon aller et venir
entre la france et le royaume uni de la
même manière donc c'est le la marque je
crois que c'était un peu un clin d'oeil
c'est elle a réalisé quelque chose qui
pouvait être kiki et qui relevait du
rêve puis finalement c'est elle qui a
inauguré le le tunnel sous la manche
je crois que vraiment c'est c'était une
amie de la france c'est président de la
république l'a mis dans son message
d'hommage
c'est tout à fait vrai c'est ce que l'on
ressentait et je me souviens lorsqu'elle
est venue la dernière fois à paris en
2014 s'écrie à paris de vive la reine
quand elle je dirais quand elle était
sûre sur l'île saint louis ça m'a
beaucoup marqué ah que les français
puissent un pays est vraiment
républicain puisse créer comme ça avec
autant de d'entousiasme s'exclamer vive
la reine
après une forme de paradoxe est une
boule est erronée de la part de français
qui ont coupé la tête de leroy et qui
adorait la reine d'angleterre mais c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est qu'elle va bien au delà des
symboles elle incarne tellement encore
plus qu une royauté qu'une famille
royale qui a pu être décriée d'ailleurs
on voit la dichotomie entre la reine et
le reste de la famille royale qui somme
toute a des défauts souvent très humain
on n'a pas rappelé une chose mais son
état de santé aurait beaucoup décliné
depuis qu'elle a perdu son époux donc
c'était une mère une grande
c'était aussi une épouse et elle
incarner cette stabilité de couple avec
ce couple fusionnel
son rock 1,17 elle voilà c'est un bon
rock elle était un roc elle s'appuyait
sur un roc et ce qu'il a fait aussi sa
longévité et l'angleterre c'est souvent
le pays qu'on adore détester 1 mais sont
nos voisins à quelque part ce sont un
peu nos frères ennemis il l a toujours
veillé à ce que finalement les relations
soient fluidifier entre la france et
l'angleterre elles prennent prenez
toujours la parole en français elle
avait un français excellent et quand
elle disait ses discours en français
elle montrait
à l'incarner l'amitié qu'elle voulait
montrer avec la france mais elle s'est
rendue à plusieurs reprises en france
dont une fois en 2004 au sénat et on va
voir sa vie avec entend calmer qui nous
rejoint bonjour quand on joue à les
accompagner tout au long de cette
édition spéciale évidemment et vous
avait replongé pour nous dans les
archives du sénat en 2004 la reine
elizabeth ii se rend en france pour sa
quatrième visite d'état et elle est
reçue au sénat voilà quatrième visite
d'état sur cinq au total qu'elle a
réalisés dans le pays effectivement et
c'est un souvenir on peut dire qu'il est
resté dans l'esprit de nombreux
journalistes de la chaîne un des grands
événements de l'époque pour public sénat
la reine qui est arrivé en rolls dans la
cour d'honneur du sénat accueilli à
l'époque par et christian poncelet
qu'était le président du du de la
chambre haute est également jean louis
debré à ses côtés qui lui présidait
l'assemblée nationale elles venaient
commémorer en 2004 les 100 ans de
l'entente cordiale l'accord destiné à
aplanir les différends coloniaux qu'il y
avait entre la france et le royaume uni
l'accord qui était donc signé en avril
1904 elle a pu comme ça et bien
inspecter voilà la garde républicaine
avec on voit le nombre de rangées de
gardes ce qui signifie que c'est
vraiment un événement très important
contient autant de garde dans la cour et
voilà elle est ensuite allée dans la
salle des conférences du sénat ali a
prononcé un un discours devant les
parlementaires alors pas dans
l'hémicycle mais donc dans la salle de
conférence devant le parterre des
parlementaires qui étaient réunis voilà
ont la voix qui monte le l'escalier
d'honneur du sénat et bien je vous
propose d'écouter un extrait de son
discours dans la salle des conférences
cet anniversaire donne un sens
particulier à ma visite est à la
quatrième que j'ai effectué en france
ou revenir en arrière il est l'occasion
de célébrer la clairvoyance d'un accord
qui allait jeter les bases d'une
alliance décisive qui aura permis à nos
deux pays le traverser les turbulences
du 20e siècle
on s'est tourné vers l'avenir il nous
donne à la fois l'occasion de remises et
les tensions nous avons connus récemment
et de répondre aux défis et aux
promesses temps sera fait demain
voilà voyez un le français impeccable
effectivement vous le lisiez elle
parlait très bien français l'avaient
appris le français avec sa nourrice qui
était d'origine belge dès la plus tendre
enfance elle parle de tension dans son
discours les tensions en question et
bien c'est le nom à l'époque des de la
france à la guerre en irak alors plus
inattendu devant ce parterre de députés
et de sénateurs elle a loué le rôle du
parlement et coûte un deuxième extrait
notre attachement mutuel à la démocratie
parlementaire et le socle de notre
liberté et de nos valeurs communes
la liberté bien le plus précieux que
nous ayons
or elle n'est jamais acquise
les liens que nos deux parlements
entretiennent de longue date
n'ont ni la professeur ni le périmètre
des deux parties souhaitons leur donner
les palmes on continue de jouer un rôle
immense
non seulement à l'échelle nationale mais
aussi dans l'édification de leur offre
et demande voilà c'était en 2004 il y
aura eu encore une dernière vie d'état
en 2014 et on le sert la france était au
final le pays étrangers où elle a
réalisé le plus de visites merci quand
on scrute un évidement vous revenez à
mes côtés dans quelques instants est-ce
que vous qui vise présider ce groupe
d'amitié france royaume-uni cieux sénat
céline boulay ce dernier le décès de la
reine elizabeth ça peut changer quelque
chose dans les relations entre la france
et le royaume uni alors juste pour
revenir sur ce que je viens d'entendre
c'est un peu prémonitoire parce qu'elle
rappelle le rôle essentiel du parlement
que nous allons vivre une plus que
jamais faut-il rappeler à deux reprises
en de la république dans les prochaines
semaines donc on voit qu'on d'écouté
discours absolument on lirait diffusera
est ce que votre question portait sur
est-ce que ce décès ça peut changer
quelque chose dans les relations entre
la france et le royaume-uni ont le
rappeler c'est vrai que c'est le pays
qu'elles à laquelle a le plus visité
elle parlait impeccablement français il
avait un vrai talent changement de la
reine à la france il ya un attachement
aussi de charles qui est devenu cher le
3 la france mais est ce que ce décès
peut changer quelque chose bien sûr non
mais comme comme vous dites on va voir
maintenant ce qu'il charles 3 god save
the king j'ai envie de dire va
poursuivre l'action de la reine mais il
a eu tellement de temps pour se préparer
à ses côtés je ne doute pas que du point
de vue de la diplomatie en tout cas ils
continuent cette action et continue les
bonnes relations qu'il a avec la france
je crois qu'il aime beaucoup la france
lui aussi je ne sais pas s'ils parlent
français pas à ma connaissance un petit
peu je crois mais je ne je n'obtenais
est à disko fils charles aussi pour vous
avez pas d'inquiétude les rejets de co2
qui est évidemment le breakbeat
complique tout on a vu les difficultés
autour de la pêche autour des
importations autour d'un certain nombre
de choses cela dit la reine n'est plus
il faut maintenant faire confiance à
charles iii pour continuer cette action
et je suis d'un naturel optimiste
c'est surtout au peuple britannique que
je pense aujourd'hui parce qu'avec la
crise qu'il traverse j'ai peur qu'ils
rentrent dans une espèce d'inquiétude et
sa disparition à rennes n'aidera pas
voilà donc on espère que le nouveau roi
sera aussi solide que sa défunte mère et
c'est tout le bien que je souhaite au
peuple britannique et j'aimerais me
tourner vers l'avenir pour eux je les
aime vraiment et je leur souhaite tout
milliards prix on va parler dans
quelques zones de l'avenir du peuple
britannique mais un mot sur ses
relations france royaume-uni avec vous
olivier cadic vous le lisiez emmanuel
macron bien évidemment a réagi au décès
de la reine elizabeth il salue en elle
une amie de la france est ce que il faut
y voir un écho à la déclaration de la
nouvelle premier ministre ni strauss qui
elle a refusé de dire si emmanuel macron
et c'est un ami ou un an et demi
juste avant de répondre je voulais
revenir sur le passage de la reine au
sénat puisqu'on m'a des témoins n'ont
livré une anecdote quand elle est
arrivée devant l'escalier d'honneur et
je vous rappelle qu'à ce moment là elle
avait 78 ans et cet escalier d'honneur
qui est quand même très très raide qui
est très impressionnant je crois que les
gens qui accompagnaient la reine n'avait
se sont rendu compte je dirais que
c'était quand même une épreuve qui lui
étaient imposées qui était finalement un
peu inattendu et elle l'a fait avec
beaucoup d'élégance et beaucoup de
naturel c'est pour vous montrer
justement cette capacité en toutes
circonstances de se dépasser ça peut
paraître anodin mais c'est une anectode
kim était revenu que ce qu'ils avaient
vécu avait été vraiment marqué par sa
façon de de s'affronter maintenant
effectivement je pense que le présent la
république sait manier justement ce les
messages je dirais à plusieurs niveaux
il a en exprimant sa de cette manière
évidemment beaucoup ils ont lu un
message à la première ministre en
espérant qu'elle serait inspiré par la
proche de la reine d'angleterre celle
qui justement savait être au dessus de
tout never explain mais veut complet
celle qui était capable justement
d'affronter toutes les circonstances et
d'être rassurante je pense qu'elle va
beaucoup manquer peut-être à la première
ministre elle aurait il est évident que
les chefs d'état enfin des chefs de
gouvernement pouvaient se confier à la
reine avoir son sentiment en sachant que
p absolument rien ne transparaît traits
de leurs échanges c'est je pense que
c'est très important pour un premier
ministre chef du gouvernement de pouvoir
voir ce ce regard ce miroir cet appui ça
a été d'ailleurs remarquablement dit par
le premier ministre canadien justin
trudeau qui a expliqué sa relation avec
la monarque qui justement lui donner des
conseils et qu'elle allait lui manquer
je crois que c'est c'est important pour
c'était important pour nous
effectivement pouvoir compter sur sur
l'arène pour faire passer ses messages
au premier ministre il ya eu aussi un
symbole quand elle avait fait son
discours au moment du bric site où elle
avait fait son discours en portant une
tenue qui avait des couleurs de l'union
européenne là encore une fois never
never explain mais elle savait aussi
peut-être faire passer des messages
subliminaux je pense que les tenues vous
faites bien me dire effectivement cette
tenue qui ont été beaucoup commentée
mais ses tenues elle servait aussi à
faire passer ses messages politiques
abbas certains l'ont l'ont pris comme ça
ceci étant elle a toujours
scrupuleusement
respecté la règle de ne justement jamais
interférer avec la politique nationale
de toujours rester au dessus d'être le
ciment le lien et je crois que ça a été
enfin tout le monde le reconnaît et
parfaite
céline l'a rappelé pendant cette
décennie 70 ans la fêter ce jubilé ont
été reçus les parlementaires ont été
reçus à l'ambassade du royaume uni pour
pour l'occasion c'est un règne extrême
exceptionnel et pendant soixante dix ans
elle a su tenir cette ligne et et
charles iii le prince charles désormais
le roi charles iii lui succède comme on
succède à quelqu'un qui a régné pendant
soixante dix ans et qui a marqué à ce
point l'histoire a
le prince charles a le temps la broye
maintenant a eu le temps de se préparer
au contact de sa maman et de ceux
présents à parer à toutes les
éventualités
évidemment il va y avoir une comparaison
elle était tellement populaire mais
c'est son fils il y aura
incontestablement une lune de miel il
passe pour quelqu'un de très intelligent
il sera donc s'adapter et assurer cette
continuité
d'autant que liszt chose qui vient
d'arriver va avoir fort à faire c'est la
3 une femme premier ministre de
l'histoire de la grande-bretagne le
monarque qui était une femme disparaît
c'est aussi un symbole le nouveau roi
est donc un homme et l'isf fassent si
elle déçoit les britanniques dès le
début parce qu'elle est déjà controversé
dès le début de son arrivée au pouvoir
ça va être très difficile pour elle
parce qu'il y aura inévitablement une
forme de comparaison je le pense et là
c'est une période où ça fait avec le
nouveau roi oui c'est une période
d'incertitude qui souffrent parce qu'on
l'a dit beaucoup elizabeth ii incarner
la stabilité là dans la même semaine les
britanniques ont une nouvelle première
ministre et un nouveau roi oui est ce
que c'est une période d'incertitude qui
s'ouvre moyens période d'incertitude
énorme une triple crise comme je vous le
disais avec une crise économique qui est
majeure donc c'est une période
d'incertitude énorme je pense que les
britanniques
même si c'était inévitable n'avait pas
besoin de cette tristesse la ce moment
là et d'ailleurs il ya l'effet de
sidération parce que quelque part il
avait fini par penser que la reine et
est immortel et il espérait même s'il
savait qu'elle avait des ennuis de santé
gagner quelques mois ce qui aurait
permis d'aplanir peut-être cette période
de difficultés liées à la guerre en
ukraine au contexte international et le
fait qu'elle disparaît au moment où la
grande-bretagne est en proie à des
difficultés majeures il faut espérer que
tout ça s'améliorera et c'était un bel
avenir au peuple britannique mais en
attendant on est en empathie avec eux
j'allais dire presque au niveau mondial
à la place de la reine qu'il l'a
toujours été il faut peut-être les
soutenir moralement ouais olivier cadic
vous qui évidemment connaissez bien le
royaume uni on le rappelle ça fait 25
ans que vous y habitez est ce que les
anglais accueillent favorablement
charles iii où est-ce qu'ils auraient
préféré que ce soit aux williams qui
succède directement elizabeth ii on va
regarder la cote de popularité
williams était juste derrière sa grand
mère dans un dernier sondage qui datent
de ya quelques mois charles n'est que 7e
dans la côte de popularité est ce que
c'est comment il va être accueilli
charles iii par les anglais
je pense je pense que sa cote de
popularité va monter puisque
naturellement il succède à la reine
je pense que tout le monde l'attend
comme
comme moi il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de surprise il remplace il remplaçait la
reine dans beaucoup de cérémonies depuis
quelques temps il tenait le rôle puisque
la reine ne pouvait plus participer
j'irai aux événements comme elle le
faisait par le passé c'est d'ailleurs le
prince charles qui étaient là avec eux
emmanuel macron pour le 80e anniversaire
de
comment dire de l'appel du 18 juin donc
je pense que de ce côté là il y aura pas
de problème maintenant le vous savez la
problématique de l'instabilité au
royaume uni qui a démarré avec le le
référendum du corexit faut quand même
être conscient que on a eu depuis 2000
16,4 premier ministre au royaume uni
donc là ça commence à faire vraiment
beaucoup quand on compare à quinze
premiers ministres sur 70 ans donc vous
voyez un peu la difficulté qu'ont les
britanniques la première ministre
aujourd'hui 10 trusts on n'imagine pas
qu'elle va faire un beau mandat comme
premier ministre non plus on
sent que la vraie difficulté au royaume
uni aujourd'hui maintenant c'est de
retrouver une stabilité suite au
référendum du break site de retrouver un
petit peu justement c'est une cohérence
aussi dans la direction et dans les
objectifs on voit que on est dans un
niveau de crise très important avec des
grèves à répétition on sent que
maintenant on rentre dans un un moment
où ça va être très lourd la crise qu
vida je dirais
atténuer le fait que beaucoup dont les
conséquences du break site maintenant
elles apparaissent
de plus en plus aux britanniques qui
commence à avoir à mesurer l'impact de
la sortie de l'union européenne donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation où on est président de la
république l'a très bien dit en fait le
royaume uni est forcément un allié de la
france de l'union européenne ils vont
traverser une crise qui traverse une
crise profonde
c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut se
détourner il faut il va falloir
continuer à leur tendre la main et si
eux mêmes ont des difficultés il faudra
être patient maintenant même parfois
pour deux et un mot de conclusion avec
vous c'est la noblesse polonaise sur
l'avenir on a vu sa cote de popularité
de charles alors kate middleton et le
prince william qui sont maintenant
prince et princesse de galles sont 2 et
3 auprès des britanniques dans la
popularité camilla et le roi charles iii
ne sont que 7 et 8 ça va être le premier
défi ça de charles de se faire aimer de
son peuple ça va être le premier des
filles de toute façon comme je vous le
disais c'est la stabilité et le sens du
devoir au détriment des ce trajet de
stratégie de communication
si au vu des sondages le prince charles
décidé d'écouter le peuple et de se
destituer au profit de son fils il
mettrait à mal toute sa stratégie qui a
fait le succès de la reine et la
stabilité et le fait qu'elle est
incarner l'unité et le destin du peuple
britannique il a donc intérêt selon moi
500 créé dans cette tradition on dit de
lui qu'il aime communiquer au détriment
de ce que lui impose la constitution et
qu'il aime parler sur l'environnement
sur d'autres sujets qu'il est parfois
reproché anti lui reprocher parce qu'il
peut parler à tort et à travers
et paradoxalement l'un des succès la
reine d'angleterre ça a été de ne jamais
parler en public vous savez qu on
reproche souvent trop politiques de
s'exprimer il ne faudrait pas que le
prince charles soit trop dans la rupture
par rapport à ce qu un carnet sa mère
surtout encore une fois à un moment le
peuple britannique a besoin de stabilité
et de réassurance merci beaucoup merci
cdi amène pyrénées d'avoir été avec nous
pour cette édition spéciale c'est un
plaisir de vous avoir sur plateau merci
également olivier cadic d'avoir été avec
nous à distance merci de nous avoir fait
part de votre réaction vous qui vivez au
royaume uni depuis 25 ans merci à tous
les deux d'avoir est avec nous
[Musique]